what are the basics can you describe
what the great barrington declaration is
what are some of the ideas in it you
mentioned focused protection
uh what are your concerns about
lockdowns just paint the picture of this
early proposal sure so uh the great
painting declaration first why is it
called great barrington declaration it
sounds it's such a great name
you you i mean it just it's such an epic
name but the the reason why it's called
that is way less than epic
it was it was because it the the
conference um which is organized by
martin kuldorf who's a was a professor
at harvard university uh by a
statistician he actually one uh
designed
the safety system the statistical system
that the
fda uses
for
tracking vaccine safety
he
and i had met previously just the summer
before that summer um and he invited me
to come to this small conference where
he was inviting me and sinatra gupta who
was a professor of theoretical
epidemiology at harvard dive at oxford
university
and um i mean i jumped at the chance uh
because i knew that martin and sinetra
were both smarter than me and it would
be fun to like talk about what what the
right strategy would be
on the drive in i didn't know what the
name of the town was and i asked
they said it was great barrington i had
in the back of my head
martin and i arrived a little early and
we were writing an op-ed about some of
the ideas i hope we'll get to talk about
very soon um about focus protection and
the right strategy and uh when sunitra
arrived we we realized we'd actually
come basically to the same place about
the right way to deal with the epidemic
um and i i thought well why don't we put
issue why don't we write something like
the port huron statement is what i had
that in the back of my head yes and i'm
like well what's the name of this town
again it was great barrington yeah so
it's not barrington
it's great bear it's which is fantastic
it's so over the top that it's perfect
it's it's
literally like the big bang
there's something about these
over-the-top fun titles that just really
deliver them
so that's why that's my my main
contribution was the word is the title
the name great barrington decor um but
yeah so it was it was kind of uh so the
the idea is actually
while the title is great um and i think
that it was written in a very stylish
way
uh it's you know like it's a go it's
less than a page you can go look online
and read it it's written written for
not for scientists but for the general
public so that people can understand the
ideas really simply
but it is not actually a radical set of
ideas it actually represents the old
pandemic plans
that we've used for century
dealing with other similar pandemics
um and and there's it's twofold uh first
let me talk about the science it rests
on and then i'll talk about the plan the
science actually some of what we already
talked about uh there's this massive age
gradient in the risk of coven infection
older people face much higher risk than
younger people
the second bit of science is all that's
not controversial right that even if you
think the ifr is 0.7 or or or 0.2 no
matter what everyone thinks everyone
agrees on this age gradient
the second bit of science is also not
controversial
the lockdown focused policies that we
followed
have absolutely devastating consequences
on the health of the population
let me just give you some examples
and this is this was known in october of
2020 we wrote it right so um the un was
sounding alarms that there would be
tens of millions of people who would
starve as a consequence of the economic
dislocation caused by the lockdowns
and that's come to pass
hundreds of thousands of children in
places like south asia dead from
starvation
as a consequence of lockdowns
um the the the
uh
priorities like
the treatment of patients with
tuberculosis
in poor countries stopped
because of lockdowns
uh
childhood vaccinations of
measles rubella
dpt you know diphtheria so on pertussis
tetanus all those standard vaccination
campaigns
stopped
tens of millions of children skipping
these doses
for diseases that are actually deadly
for them
is there just a on a small tangent
is it well understood to you what are
the mechanisms that stop all those
things because of lockdowns is it some
aspect of supply chain is it just
literally because hospital doors are
closed
is it because there's a disincentive to
go outside by people even when they
deeply need help it's all of the above
uh but a lot of those efforts like
especially those like vaccination
efforts are funded and run by what
western efforts like gavi is a
i think it's a gates funded thing
actually that produce provides vaccines
for you know millions of kids worldwide
and those efforts were scaled back
malaria prevention efforts so in the
developing world it was a devastating
effect these lockdowns um there was also
direct effects like in india the
uh the lockdowns when they first
instituted there was an order that 10
million migrant workers
who live in big cities and they live
hand-to-mouth they buy you know coconuts
they sell the coconuts with the money
they buy food for themselves and
coconuts for the next day to sell
walk back to their villages or get or
get go back to their villages then
overnight so 10 million people walking
back to their villages or taking a train
back a thousand died on route
overcrowded trains dying essentially on
the side of the road i mean it was it
was absolutely inhumane policy
uh and uh the lockdowns there
what what it's it's actually it's kind
of like what's happened to the west as
well but it was so severe uh there was a
zero prevalence study done in mumbai by
a friend of mine at the university of
chicago what he found was that in the
slums of mumbai
there were seventy percent surah
prevalence in july or august of
sept of 2020 whereas in the rest of
mumbai was 20
yeah right so it was incredibly unequal
the the lockdowns protected the the
relatively well off and spread the
disease and among the poor
um so
that's in the developing world
in the developed world the health
effects of lockdowns were
also quite bad
right so we talked already about
isolation and depression there was a
study done in july of 2020
that found that one in four young adults
seriously considered suicide now suicide
rates haven't like spiked up
so much but the depths of despair that
would lead somebody to seriously
consider suicide itself should be should
be a source of great concern for in
public health
yeah this is one of the troubling things
about measuring well-being is
we're okay at measuring death and
suicide
we're not so good at measuring suffering
it's like people talk about
um maybe even
holomore in the under stalin
or the concentration camps with hitler
we talk about deaths but we don't talk
about
the suffering over periods of years
by people living in fear by people
starving
psychological trauma that lasts a
lifetime all of those things
i mean and just to get back to that that
point we close schools especially in
blue states we close schools
um now richer parents could send their
kids to private schools many of which
stayed open even in the blue states they
could get pods they could get tutors but
that's not true for for poorer and
middle-class parents
and as a result what we did is we took
away life opportunities for kids we we
tried to teach
five-year-olds to read via zoom in
kindergarten
right uh
and uh the consequence actually you
think okay we can just make it up but
it's really difficult to make that up
um there's a literature in health
economics that shows that even
relatively small disruptions in
schooling can have lifelong consequences
negative consequences for kids
right so they end up growing up poorer
they they lead shorter lives and less
healthy lives
as a consequence that's and that's what
the literature now shows is is likely to
happen with the interruptions of
schooling that we had in the united
states many european countries actually
managed to avoid this there were in the
early days the epidemic great
indications that children first were not
very severe severely at risk from covet
itself
nor are they super spreaders
schools were not the source of community
spread communities spread spread
the disease to schools not the other way
around
and if we can talk about the scientific
base of that if you'd like but that was
pretty well known even in october
um it that we we closed hospitals in
order to keep them
like available to covet patients but as
a result
women skipped breast cancer screening
as a result they have are showing up
with late stage breast cancer that
should have been picked up last year
men and women skipped colon cancer
screening again with later stage disease
that should have been picked up last
year with earlier stage
for patients with diabetes
it's very important to have regular
screening for blood sugar levels
and and sort of counseling for lifestyle
improvement and we skipped that
people stayed home with heart attacks
and died at home with heart attacks
so you had this like sort of wide range
of medical
and psychological harms
that were being utterly ignored
as a result of the lockdowns
plus there's the economic pain
so like you said the
whatever is a good term for the
non-laptop class
people would lose their jobs yes there
might be in the in the western world
support for them
financially but the the big loss there
that is perhaps correlated with the
depression and suicide is uh
loss of meaning loss of hope for the
future a loss of kind of a sense of
stability all the pride you have and
being able to um
make
money that allows you to pave your own
way in the world
and yes just having less money than
you're used to so your family your kids
are suffering all those kinds of things
and there's a there's like again an
economics literature on this on deaths
of despair it was called 2009 there was
the the great recession it led to an
enormous uptick in overdose from drugs
suicidality depression
as a result of the job losses that
happened during the great recession
well that's happening again like an
enormous increase
in drug overdoses
that's not uh that's not a an accident
that's a lockdown harm right same same
thing with uh with the job losses the
job losses by the way are like it's so
interesting because the
um the states that stayed open have had
much much lower unemployment than the
states that stayed closed
uh the labor force participation rates
declined by three percent it's women
that separated because
they stayed home with their kids
um we've reversed a generation of women
uh when
proving women's participation in the
labor force
do you think uh
it has to do with the institutions that
uh we mentioned that there is so much
priority given or so much power given to
maybe nih
versus um
other civilian leaders or do people just
not care about the economic pain the
leaders i mean uh because to me it was
obvious
i mean probably is just studying history
whenever i listen to people on twitter
or on mainstream news or just anything
i realize that's the very kind of top
the people that have a voice
represent a tiny selection of people and
so whenever there's hard times i always
kind of uh think about the quiet
the voiceless
the quiet suffering of the tens of
millions of the hundreds of millions
um
due to political leaders not just give a
damn i mean i think it was actually a
very odd ethical thing at the beginning
of the pandemic where if you brought up
economic harms at all
you were seen as callous
right so i i i had a reporter calling me
up almost the very beginning of the
epidemic asking me about about the about
uh
like a very particular phenomenon so
like uh he he was anticipating a rise in
child abuse because children were gonna
be staying at home child abuse is
generally picked up at school
and that actually happened like so like
the child reported child abuse dropped
but actual child abuse increased um
because normally you pick up the child
abuse at school and that you apparently
you have the intervention right so yeah
i sort of started talking about like
well there's gonna be some economic
harms and they're gonna have health
consequences but the economic harms
matter but the but he he counseled me
and i think he was he had his bet my
best interest at heart like if if you
were to put that in the story i would be
i'd essentially be canceled because the
what the what the uh the the narrative
that that arose in march of 2020 is if
you if you care about money at all
you're evil and crass if you you must
only care about lives
the problem with that narrative is that
that money which we're talking about is
is actually lives of poor people
right when you throw 100 million people
around the world into into poverty
you're going to see enormous harm to
their health enormous increases in their
in their mortality it's not immoral to
think about that and and worry about
that
in the context of this pandemic response
our mind focused so much on kovid that
it forgot that there are so many other
public health priorities as well that
need our attention desperately
you